c'est un premier ministre souriant qui
vient s'exprimer devant la presse après
la publication des premiers résultats
selon les estimations le parti libéral
vvd a obtenu 35 sièges sur les 150 de la
chambre basse du parlement néerlandais
en résultat qui devrait permettre à marc
route de diriger sa quatrième coalition
gouvernementale je suis très content
très heureux pour la quatrième fois et
c'est très spécial je le suis aussi
d'avoir eu l'honneur de gérer certaines
crises majeures la récession la crise
des réfugiés et maintenant la crise du
coronavirus en tant que grand parti cela
nous rend très humble c'est un immense
honneur au pouvoir depuis 2010 marque
coûteux avait démissionné mi janvier sur
fond de scandales financiers tout en
poursuivant la gestion des affaires
courantes
désormais il va pouvoir former son
nouveau gouvernement le premier ministre
néerlandais a jugé probable une
coalition avec deux parties le d66
sociales libérales et les chrétiens
démocrates
il a en revanche exclu toute négociation
avec les députés du parti d'extrême
droite de geert wilders le pvv
ce dernier a assuré qu'il continuera à
faire entendre sa voix je pense que nous
sommes toujours le troisième parti des
pays-bas
si les proportions sont toujours comme
on les voit nous sommes probablement de
nouveau le plus grand parti d'opposition
et puis nous ferons entendre la voix du
pvv
depuis l'opposition avec beaucoup de
force et d' enthousiasme dans les années
à venir
ces législatives néerlandaises se sont
déroulés durant trois jours pour
permettre aux électeurs les plus
vulnérables de voter avec un minimum de
risques
le scrutin constituait aussi un test
pour le gouvernement sortant en partie
jugée sur sa gestion de la crise
sanitaire
une stratégie évolutive avec des mesures
renforcées peu à peu depuis un an après
avoir misé sur l'immunité collective
l'exécutif a durci sa position depuis
septembre
restaurant bar écoles fermées couvre
peut imposer malgré de violentes
manifestations les autorités ont tenu le
cap et convaincu les électeurs de leur
redonner leur confiance le nouveau
gouvernement va désormais devoir se
concentrer sur la campagne de
vaccination ralenti après la suspension
pour deux semaines du vaccin
d'astrazeneca plus de un million neuf
cent mille doses ont été administrées
jusqu'à présent aux pays bas